a deadly salmonella outbreak linked to
turkey in the u.s. is spreading the
jennie-o turkey store-brand were called
more than one hundred and sixty-four
thousand additional pounds of raw ground
turkey last Friday and a Warner is here
with what you need to know and a good
morning right and talk about bad timing
this latest turkey recall the second in
just two months you should check your
freezer and make sure you don't have any
of these contaminated packages the seven
products that are recalled were produced
on October 22nd and 23rd and shipped
across the country they include one
pound two and a half pound and three
pound packages of ground turkey taco
seasoned ground turkey stater brothers
ground turkey and Italian seasoned
ground turkey all of the items are sold
at Safeway and giant supermarkets now
more than 91 thousand pounds of jennie-o
ground turkey were recalled last month
because of Salmonella concerns over all
there have been 216 reported cases of
Salmonella illnesses across 38 states in
the past year and one was deadly so to
protect yourself in general to prevent
Salmonella you shouldn't do things
including washing your hands but if you
have any of these products in your home
you should throw them out get rid of
them don't use them don't eat them it
feels like it's one thing after another
there's a recall every day when it comes
to whether it be the ground turkey or
lettuce or something it just feels right
every day right and the latest one
before this was romaine which they're
still looking for the source of the
contamination so they found one farm but
I think they're still looking to see
whether there were other implicating
vectors on that one so yeah it's
parallel pantry yeah it's got a Carol be
careful Tony - Kashar